皆さんこんにちは編まず土地前ですがあ
前ですが皆さんこの景色どこかわかりますか
ここはみなみ信州長野県の中でも南信州なんですが
そこにある村の風景ですこの子わかりましたねー
長野県民でも読める人は少ないかと思います
この子実の泰阜村というんですが
泰阜村で私はたらしています
そんな村で私が始めたことですが毛も彼はプロジェクト
女猟師の贈り物という題で
プロジェクトをやっております
これを始めたきっかけは
この子でした
このどう打つ知ってます
ニホンジカです私は高校時代
この日本時間を高校で育てましたそれがきっかけで私は鹿がすごく大好きになったん
ですが
し彼を好きになったと同時に有害鳥獣という言葉を知りました
有害鳥獣ということが皆さん知ってますかね
なが馬券だと当たり前のように多分使っているかと思うんですが
日本において野生動物っていうのが仕方とかイノシシサルクマ
いろんな動物がいますいろんな動物がいる中で日本では田畑を荒らしたりですとか
あるいは
林業に影響を与えたりですとか
いろんな生態系に影響を与えていい
大きな問題になっています
にそんな中で
大きな問題を与えているシカやイノシシ野生鳥獣を
有害鳥獣と呼んで捕獲するように国から言われているんです
約80万等これは日本で1年間に取られている獣の数です
その多くは
お肉として食べられることもなく変わっとかも活用されることもなく
山に埋められているという現状がありました
私はそれを知った時とても衝撃でどうにかできないかな自分が大好きな子かのために
何かできないかなっていうことを思いました
そこで立ち上げたのがこのプロジェクトです
皆さん気も川之江になんとなくわかりますか
てもの可愛いと
てもののかわいい
この2つを合わせた
造語が
ても彼はという言葉です
獣かわいいのかわいいには
昔もともと言葉の意味としては不憫だとかての毒だっていう意味があったらしいですが
今は愛らしい愛おしいという言葉で使われています
その可愛い愛らしい愛おしいという言葉を含んだ言葉に
恵みという言葉があります
この恵っていう言葉なんですけどこの件も変わっていう獣かわいいの中には
獣は山の恵みである自然の恵みであるっていう言葉も含めて
意味として付けてあります
名前ってすごく大事ですよね
この件も変わっていう言葉が私の活動の一番最初にくる言葉です
なのでこの言葉を看板にしていろんな人に自然と思いを伝えていっているんです
サブテーマでつけているこの女猟師の贈り物このかと言葉の通り
私は表紙です
白こんな格好してますが普段はこういうふうに指定のオレンジ色のベストを着て
後オレンジ色の帽子をかぶってしたはモンテで上は長袖を着て出足は地下足袋を履いて
そんな格好で山に入っています
これ泰阜村の漁師さんたちと山に寮に行った時の写真なんですがこんな風に山を歩いて
着物を取ったりですとか
鉄砲で撃ったりしてとって方法とあとは
これまだで取る方法があります
このままのは笠松式はなと言って泰阜村で多く使われているものなんですけれども
こんな風にワイヤーをまだの土台にかけてぎゅっと引っ張って花を閉めますそして
獣が歩いてくる道にこのままを埋めて隠してそこに獣が通ってくる
あの棒が明日と思うと
ああああああ
足が入った時にかちゃんと閉まって取られるという軸になっています
私はこの方法で獣今とっています
そうして取られた獣たち南信州泰阜村では鹿が主には取られるんですが
100年以上も昔からお肉を食べる文化がありました
実は今も食べ続けられているしお肉を売っているところがたくさんあります
なのでお肉をどうにかするということは私の中ではなくてもっと別の形でしかのことを
言うが胃腸症のことに関われないかなーっていうことを考えました
そして気づいたのがこれです
これは
真っ白いんですが鹿の革です
彼はっていうのは実は昔から日本の中では使われていて
これ手袋っぽいやつなんですが昔からあるブドウ
弓道ですね弓道のこっち側の手に付けて使う道具です
こういったものですとかあるいは鎧の中に使われていたりあるいはシリカはとして山に
入っていたり
いろんな形で暮らしの中にありました
つまり家も彼はは日本の中に昔から
文化の中にあったものなんだなっていうことを感じました
大事にしているのは獣の命いただきますっていうことです
これを伝えながら活動しています
なので命をいただくということはやっぱり暮らしの中に大事に使っていくことで
伝えられるのかなっていうことでまず最初に作ったのがこちらの今私も付けている
名札ですね
村の職員の人たちにこれをつけてもらっています
これは鹿の皮で作ったやつです
ただし彼の皮で作るだけじゃ面白くないので4つ合わせると村のマークができる
そんなものにしました
そこにはきちんとメッセージも込められていて
村っていうのは小さな村でやっぱり職員一人一人の力がすごく重要で村の人一人ひとり
の力が大事なんですね
なのでそんな一人一人の力が合わさって無駄ができているんだよっていう意味でこの
デザインにしました
こんな風なものを作ったりあとは
パスケースですねをチクったりこちらは鍵の形の名札
そして携帯クリーナーストラップ
7ない理由のスリーパー
ベリーシューズこんな暮らしの道具もいろいろと考えて作り上げていきました
暮らしの道具いろんなものがあるんですが
今私が手につけているものこちらも
その鹿の皮で作ったものです見えましたね
これはさっき出したこの商品たち
これらはきれいな部分で作っています
平成代物なのでもちろん記事があったりとか痛みがあったり川の味さに個性があります
それらの作った商品の始めてきた革ハギレで私は冬
手首が寒くなる知って乾燥するでいろんなハンドル切った時に滑ってしまう
あるいは鉄砲を持った時に滑ってしまうかもしれないっていうことで
でも指先は感覚を残しておきたいですとかそんな思いから
あっ端切れで超えて甘いたらなんとなくて袋の形だねっていうのでこの手袋を作って
もらいました
でこうやって日常的に使っていたでですとか
あとはこちらですね
これ
ジャンベっていうアフリカの太鼓を参考にチクったタイプなんですが
こちらはこういった川とはまた違う方法で作られています
この手でつけている手袋や画面に出ている
商品等は全て工場で鞣された
つまり柔らかくして
ちょっと成分を変えて長く使えるようにしたものです
こっちの顔はしかを取った生の皮をお肉を削いで気を抜いて乾かした
それだけのものです
昔からじゃあ8瓦木の皮を使って作られていたんですかああこれは大胆ヌード
うん
今ばがします
これはを切れノートなどで割と低い音がしますが
こっちの
ちっちゃい体子ですね
ちっちゃいとエコは
ん
感じの音がします
もちろん彼はなので場所に呼んでー
いろんな音がありますうん
生の川なので湿気がある日なんかは緩んだりとか
あれ音が変わったりいろんな音を出してくれます
こんな風に音楽も
川で生まれていきますくらしの中を
弟後はいろんな触った感じですとかいろんなもので満たしてくれる豊かにしてくれる
ものなんです
これらを作っているのが
村のお母さんたち
です
私は私と後協力隊の仲間2人
そして無駄の小さい子供を持つお母さんたちですね
いい手伝ってもらって今作っているんですがこのお母さんたちにした理由なんでだと
思います
私泰阜村というか長野県に来て一番感じたのが
団扇と女性とでコミュニケーションの取り方が全然違うなっていうのを感じたんです
男性は
必ず必要なのがお酒とおつまみ
これがないとコミュニケーションのなかなか撮れません
本音が言えないんですねね女性の場合はお酒等つまりはそんなにいらないんですね何が
いるかというとお茶とお菓子
あと漬物ですね長野県は
これがあると話が弾んでコミュニケーションが取れるようになるんです
で a
さすがに
商品を作っていく上でお酒を飲みながらとかっていうわけにはいかないし
できるならば楽しい場でありたいと思ったときに
そして私は母親にもこれからなっていくであろう3です
多分なると思いますなのでそんな時にやっぱり子供が生まれたらきっと子育ても
しっかりやりたい
でもちっちゃい時って保育園にもなかなか預けられないし一生懸命やっぱり自分で
子育てをしたいと思う
だからたまに空いた時間で何かできるようなそうな仕事の場をつくりたいなと
をでもとが家に1人で来持ってやるのもちょっと寂しいし色んなお母さんたちと
ワイワイしゃべりだからやれたら楽しいんだろうなーっていうことを思ったときに
小さいおかあさん小さい子どもたちのいるお母さん
密かな人たちに手伝ってもらうのが一番いいだろうっていうことにたどり着きました
実際は政策をこれに最初始めた頃の感じなんですが
これ写真なんで全く声は伝わってきませんがこれ作ってる最中ツーっとお母さんた
しゃべり続けています
私も一緒に喋ってるんですがやっぱりまだしゃべれいただいてないので
あのつい気が止まってしまうんですがわかるさんたちはずーっとしゃべりながら
しっかりても動かしてしっかり仕事をしてくれています
なのでこんな場を作ることで子育てもできて
仕事もチャップできてなおかつお母さんたちが楽しめて子供がそんなお母さんの姿を見
て気も母のことを知っていく命のことを伝えていけるそんなばができたらいいなという
ことを考えています
てもカープロジェクト今まだまだ走り出しのプロジェクトです
できてまだ2年しかたっておらずようやく仲間も増えてきたところです
お母さんたちが最初は一人二人だったのが三人四人になって仲間を呼んできて
今7人まで増えました
猟友会の皆さんたちも泰阜村だけで50人以上の方達がいます
そして札の方たちが応援してくれて県内の方達も応援してくれて
そんな風に今広げて言っていますこれからきっとスマートあるであろう人たちと
そしてきっと今ここで話を聞いてくれている皆さんも多分
応援してくれるであろうと指示しています
気も化プロジェクトこれからもシャキどんどんどんどん
思いを伝えていくために活動していきますが皆さんもどうぞ応援よろしくお願いします
そして
またお会いできる日を楽しみにしています今日はありがとうございました